[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka
mr give your girl ditkovic in this [ __ ]
in this video we're breaking down how
doctor octopus will be returning for
spider-man no way home
alfred molina dropped a big interview
last week that made me crown him the new
spoiler man
and there's a lot to talk about in it
we're also going to be discussing how
this links in with jamie foxx's electro
as well as some plot leaks towards the
end of the video now if you enjoyed then
please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you subscribe for the best
videos on the web that you definitely
want to stick around for
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our spider-man
no way home breakdown
okay so the upcoming film is gonna have
a hell of a lot on its plate
not only is the movie gonna be tackling
the fallout of peter being framed for
the murder of mysterio
but it's also gonna open up the
multiverse and bring across several
characters from both the raimi trilogy
and the amazing spider-man
marvel normally remain pretty
tight-lipped about their productions
and though things can get out from time
to time on the whole i'd say that the
studio is pretty good at keeping things
under wraps
sony on the other hand especially tom
holland
that lad will tell you anything after he
sniffed a shandy
and over the years you've probably seen
that they very much just dropped things
in the middle of interviews for a laugh
my highly reliable source dude bro trust
me told me that marvel studios was
pretty annoyed that they had a
spider-man murderer poster in the mobius
trailer
and according to several sources on
venom they even filmed a scene with tom
holland that mickey made them cut
when things like this get out i often
believe that it's because this studio
want to see an increase in their share
price
and whilst disney have done well in the
pandemic due to their streaming service
sony have probably struggled heck i
can't even get a ps5
so they need to announce whatever they
can to keep things positive
now alfred molina played doctor octopus
in spider-man 2
and in my opinion it's one of the best
comic book movies ever made
he recently did an interview with
variety whilst promoting promising young
women
and let a lot slip out he said that when
spider-man 2 was being filmed everything
was kept under wraps
but with this project it's all over the
internet so he didn't mind spilling the
beans
pain now molina has revealed that he's
coming back as a brand new character
called doc [ __ ] just kidding and he is
going back as
dr octopus when discussing the role the
actor stated that
though he's 17 years older than when he
first played the character
that he would be the aged for the film
now there are obviously a lot of
questions surrounding this
and molina discussed with director john
watts how he would still be alive
and he said that he was simply told in
this universe
no one really dies so yay that entire
character rocking spider-man 2 about him
becoming a good guy after freeing
himself of the grief of the death of his
wife and the tentacles was pointless yay
corporations now i i am actually quite
excited for it
and molina did say that no a home would
start off at the end of spider-man 2
with doctor octopus in the river in case
you haven't seen the movie
doc ock was obsessed with creating a
fusion reactor
that would provide clean energy this
malfunctioned and bonded his mechanical
arms to his body
now i never understood why that was the
big scientific breakthrough in the film
and not the amazing mechanical arms that
would make the human race sleep
forward millions of years on the
evolutionary treadmill
in terms of what we could do but it's a
giant big sun that takes the forefront
it's just a giant big sun now doc ock
ended up endangering the city
by trying to carry out the experiment
but peter parker talked
him around into bringing an end to the
madness the film ended with him drowning
the sun in order to stop it from
destroying the city
and he apparently died along with it now
molina has clarified that
though his final words were i won't die
a monster that he will have somewhat of
a change of heart when he travels to the
mcu
and once more he will become a villain i
really hope they make him more than just
a cackling bad guy and that they develop
a relationship between him and holland
so it's not just the mcu peter parker
tackling the villain for
just reasons i know i sound like i'm
gonna cry now
but it's only because i care that i'm so
passionate about this film doing well
i think that with the character they're
gonna lean heavily into the line about
him not leaving his work unfinished
and there is something in the plot leak
that kind of ties everything together
now though this has never been clarified
i think that the sun aqua's trying to
recreate
holds the key to how he will get into
the mcu ark was of course trying to
create his own star
and when they die the internal
thermonuclear fuels within their cores
become unstable
and they start to massively alter the
gravity around them
stars actually collapse inwards upon
themselves whilst the outer layers of
them are blown away
and this creates a black hole in sci-fi
black holes are used all the time as
either wormholes
or ways to travel across vast distances
of space
therefore it makes a lot of sense that
you'd be able to travel from one
dimension to the next
by simply going through one thus i can
see this being the way that ok is taken
across
now we also know that jamie foxx is
reprising his role as electro
and though he wasn't sucked into his son
his death also opened up a possibility
for him to return in the film as the
same character from the blue man group
fox was overcharged and this caused the
villain to explode
and vanish into thin air however like
arc he too could have been transported
to another dimension
aka the mcu one now this is often
referred to as the prime timeline
so it makes sense that both characters
would journey here as opposed to ending
up on
any other infinite amount of earths i
say it makes sense but
yeah comic books anyway molina has
stated that he's going to be d
aged for the film and though i don't
know if this will be throughout the
entire movie
we're just going to have to see it is a
lot of effects to keep up for a full
film
and though it worked with sam jackson
and captain marvel that guy's like a
vampire so
he looks younger than i do now now in
discussing the limitations of the aging
molina brought up robert de niro and the
irishman and said that you could tell he
was an older guy when he was fighting
however to me if you look at that it's
pure cinema
pure cinema that is he did however say
that it's mainly the tentacles doing the
work
but i could possibly see them just
having him go over to the universe
and then have him remain in that for the
remainder of the mcu though he is a guy
with giant tentacles so meh
maybe they will just de-age him for the
entire film now
with these two big baddies in the mcu i
can see tom holland needing some help
and this will potentially involve doctor
strange pulling toby maguire
and andrew garfield from the multiverse
though as of recording this they haven't
been confirmed for the film
we all know they're in it yeah just tell
us we already know
just tell us and that takes us to the
plot leaks which we will be discussing
in just a bit before that though i just
want to let you know that on the 30th of
april we're giving away three copies of
zack snyder's justice league and 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the film
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavy
spoilers
now this comes from reddit user
spidey245
who correctly posted that julie louis
dreyfus would be the marvel character
and falcon in the winter soldier episode
5.
as always take these with a pinch of
salt but i have spoken to a scooper who
said that this is pretty much what
happens
could be guesses could be real but
obviously we won't know until the movie
releases
now according to them we start off where
far from home ended
and there's a time jump to peter in
court it's likely that matt murdock is
the character's lawyer
and he's trying to help him prove his
innocence the film will also see doctor
strange calling on peter because
apparently the multiverse is breaking
and there are villains from other worlds
entering the mcu
according to the user the sinister six
will be made up of the green goblin
docock sandman the lizard rhino and
electro
green goblin will be played by willem
dafoe who is supposed to be the main
villain of the piece
and i really hope that his costume
resembles the original design that
raymie had for him
turns out that peter had tried to clear
his name by using magic
and that this is what broke the
multiverse since then strange has been
trying to repair it
and get all these villains into a
magical prison
the user says that toby maguire and
andrew garfield are in the second and
third act of the movie
and that they will help him to capture
the bad guys the movie's final act is on
the statue
of liberty that now looks like a big
captain america
complete with a shield we did see a bus
poster for this in the leaked images of
the set
and thus it does seem likely that this
could be happening in the film
apparently the villains want to get an
awk reactor which is sort of similar to
the whole sun thing
and that's the main macguffin in the
movie they're all transported to the
prison at the end of the film
and the user says we end with holland's
pr graduating high school
interestingly they said that everyone
still knows he's peter parker by the end
of the film
and they also said there's a big death
but that they didn't know who it was
now stuff like that kind of makes me a
bit suspect
as if you didn't know all the plot leaks
and stuff then
surely you would know who that is
however i've had my doubters when i've
been told stuff too
so i don't know if this is just good
guesswork or if it's actually the
structure of the film
either way that's the big league that's
floating around at the moment
so let me know what you think in the
comments section below if you enjoyed
the video the thumbs up is much
appreciated
and if you want something else to watch
then make sure you check out our
breakdown of our theories for the finale
of falcon in the winter soldier
it's going to be linked on screen right
now so definitely give it a watch after
this
without the way thank you for sticking
through the video i've been poor i'll
see you next time
take care peace